is this real y'all see this I am going
to put my glamour award somewhere like
right by my Oscar table and my pastor
award because this is just as much an
amazing honor that I'm going to put my
gunner award up my ass no I'm not I'm
going to have to put it in the basement
because I used to keep them on top of my
piano
but then my daughter complained it was
muscling her piano sounds oh my god I
can't believe I won the glamour Woman of
the Year 2014 Trailblazer award given to
Kristen Wiig that's what this says I
think I'm going to fasten it to the
front of my motorcycle so that people
know that I've won it and also it can
serve as like a shield for bugs oh my
god I'm going to keep this camera ward I
think probably in my handbag best
accessory you could ever have I'll just
whip it out look what I won it's going
to have to go in our office because
otherwise we are going to see about it
unless we do week on week off I'm going
to put it on the breakfast table so I
can have my breakfast with it the
following day my glamour award is going
to go on the shelf next to my other
glamour award I'd like to collect them I
don't know what I'll keep I'd I am I'm
maybe I'll give it to my mum this is
idea yeah I think most of my awards are
sort of in a storage facility in like in
Enfield I think so but I wouldn't want
to put this in there so maybe I'll maybe
I'll give it to my mum
well I live in my sister and my two best
friends so the ward will probably get
lost
among all the clothes but we have this
bookshelf with those are crazy stuff on
it and it will probably go there
somewhere